it is an honor to be on this desk every
day it really is but what we've just
witnessed is the problem with this show
where we create narratives that do not
exist in reality
the implication what you are implying
that the white voters that vote on NBA
are racist that are they favor white
people you just said that yes you did uh
yes you did I did yes you did that is
exactly what you implied that is exactly
what you applied hold on hold on I did
not go I stated the facts I stated the
facts and you're not about to sit up we
all know what you implied the other day
we all know what you implied
at the time it's the
facts it is
I think so basically Adam what Perkins
was saying is that they're it's it's
racist because it's it's a white guy
what is this the third time that he's
gonna win potentially they're talking
about the colony for Denver Nuggets and
he was so he said yeah he said something
along the way in the top three of the
MVP race for the last three years he
wanted the last two years running and
he's averaging a triple double this year
yeah and essentially the storyline is
that white voters
prefer to vote for white MVPs uh over
black players black MVPs yeah so which
to me this is what Jay day is like JJ
Redick is basically like dude you're
ridiculous yeah because then even you've
said what Charles Barkley had to say
well please Charles Barkley went in on
Kendrick Perkins he says you suffer from
ESPN disease okay he says basically you
know what the hell you're talking about
you're all caught up in this you know
how many white MVPs there have been in
the last 30 years how many okay I think
I think Steve Nash won it twice yeah
jokic has now won it twice possibly a
third time and I think you got to go
back to like the late 80s
okay since then Kevin Durant James
Harden LeBron uh KD Hardin Russell
Westbrook Giannis like the list goes on
and on so you know so what 10 of the
time a white guy wins by the way here's
what people have to realize I don't
think people realize JJ Redick is not
a republican no JJ Redick is not a trump
guy JJ's Reddick trashed Trump just a
few years ago talking about the fact
that waking up in the morning and having
breakfast you should wake up in the
morning have breakfast and criticize
Trump because that's the right thing to
do like JJ is not in this it looks like
well yeah you know he's a republican as
conservative is this no all he's saying
is dude what the hell you doing here man
like and by the way if if uh if Kendrick
Perkins wants to play the racist game
why is the NBA 70 black tell why is the
NBA 70 black why while America is 13
black why is the NBA 70 black why does
the NBA not have enough whites while
America is 22 23 Hispanic why isn't the
NBA have a lot of Jose's plane in it
yeah
how come we don't have a Ricardo Aguilar
starting you know three guard for
freaking LA Clippers how come we don't
have that a lot that's racist right yeah
no his logic doesn't make any sense but
by the way
you have to realize that to me this is
my opinion this is my opinion
I go to ESPN to interview Stephen A
Smith yeah I've been looking forward to
interviewing Stephen A Smith
while we're going out there
he knows this is you know I've done
magic Kobe I've done a lot of different
things
ESPN comes up to me and they're like
look I just finished my interview with
Ray dalio and they said hey Patrick you
can't talk to him about politics ESPN's
asked me to cut the interview wow I said
what do you mean I'm just going to ask
what if he wants to talk about it even
if he does want to talk about it we'll
cut the interview so what are you
talking about yeah we're going to cut
the unit by the way if you look at the
set of my interview it you'll you'll
recognize the set go on YouTube Type in
uh Stephen A Smith with David you have
to see this they won't even let you talk
anything when you see our set you're
gonna know where this set is just look
at the set okay look at the set look at
the set click on it
I won't flag it
come on you know what set that is that's
ESPN set go go go up or you show them
both of us together like we're all
sitting that decimal go go write the
pause right there yeah you know that set
yeah that's ESPN set there's ESPN guys
right on this side watching looking at
me saying you can't talk about that wow
and I'm about to go into it you can't
talk about that and Mario's Like Pat I
don't know what to do Mario's trying to
tell the guy let him ask the question
yeah he couldn't talk well anyway Steven
A started talking about politics
I think Stephen A is uh in a tough place
and the tough place I think he's in
right now
he has sometimes in life when your
philosophies outgrow your peers
and you become clear about your
philosophies but you're still in a
community where your peers haven't
outgrown those philosophies of
victimhood all this other stuff
you you sit there privately and you have
to make a decision and the decision is
this man do I compromise all my friends
in the community I'm a part of to
say the truth stand up for what I now
believe in or do I keep these
relationships what do I do and I think a
lot of people believe it or not they
compromise and they don't want to lose
those relationships it's not an easy
place to be because you immediately
become lonely you immediately go from
getting 79
000 likes on Instagram posts to 13 000
likes yeah you immediately go from
getting you know 693 000 views on a
first a clip to 173 000 views and that's
a scary thought okay and ESPN right now
is getting killed uh clay Travis is
saying that these guys are going to go
out of business in no time I don't know
if that's going to happen I think
they're going to let go of a lot of
their lower level talent I think that
could possibly happen and if you think
about the companies that Disney is
willing to sell this is definitely one
of them yeah I was just gonna say who
owns ESPN they're willing to sell it so
actually they're shopping it yeah
exactly quietly that's how they divided
the companies into three different
categories so they can one by one sell
them okay so so exactly Bob iger's a
genius so they want to sell ESPN because
they've already seen a writing on the
wall but you know here's here's a crazy
question for you what's the opposite
side of ears what is the ESPN competitor
Sports
there's no note about that like Barstool
never ever watch like I still till today
we will watch ESPN News I don't know if
I've watched any Fox News sports back in
the days I used to when it was good I
don't know if I've watched a Fox News
sport now it's one of the few monoliths
ESPN ESPN sports ESPN sports
yeah ESPN is 10 National channels FYI
there's nothing like FYI FYI We're not
gonna do it but somebody ought to do it
it's a wide open space for somebody to
compete directly with ESPN I think
there's a Marketplace for it because for
the fact that JJ Reddick just made a
basic comment like that and that video
got 15 million views yeah you know what
it tells you there's 15 million people
that would subscribe to your show if you
had a conservative you know competitor
to ESPN and there's not it's not out
there big time no company direct
competitors number one fox look how
shitty it is that nobody watches
Awards what about ESPN the Ocho okay
remember that yeah yeah look at number
two it's Star Sports Star Sports keep
going down the list yeah who the hell is
Star Sports
NBC okay four keep going
animals
just really fast I know we have to go
but what do you guys think uh uh
Kendrick perkins's intention was to say
something like that is it to get
eyeballs it's to prove a point why do
you think he would say that when you
know it's fault when he knows it's false
can I tell you what please go ahead I'll
tell you what Charles Barkley had to say
because that's a credible Voice who
speaks his mind oh yeah you don't give a
I don't know too many people that
hate Charles Barkley these days no you
don't give people like this yeah so he
says argument between Reddick and
Perkins apparently had been simmering
for over a week and Barkley said that he
was happy to see Reddick challenge
Perkins on his opinion quote unquote
this crossed the line JJ is the only
person to challenge perk last week and
I'm glad he did it because when I heard
it first I said man that's got to be one
of the stupidest things I had ever heard
Berkeley mentioned that race was such a
touchy subject when he particularly
bothered this about this argument he
added that the MVP analyst just often
don't analyze MVP races probably because
they don't consider it is directly a
strictly regular season award so
essentially Barclay lavish praised on
jokic the MVP candidate again and credit
him for not chasing stats something that
he mentioned should be accounted for the
MVP steps this got black white European
gray yellow Asian I don't give a
this guy jokic is an MVP candidate and
deserves all the praise and the
acknowledgment he has received so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here